surfing on the success of this bit some
candidate an experiment any piece voted
in plenary a report which will unify the
rules from the European Parliament
elections across the 28 member states we
want to make the next European elections
more attractive for the citizens and
more European in its character with a
reformed electoral lo M EPS want to make
elections to the EU Parliament more
visible for citizens but some measures
do not agree with the smaller parties
Europe doesn't need a threshold as the
asterix parties were small but we strong
we only have one member in the party and
that never was a problem gender balance
in the lists is another sticking point
photos pro podemos la parada de janeiro
mujer hombre mujer hombre hombre mujer
hombre mujer insist a McCray molera SI
NOS dijo que si pero luego parece que no
porque la misma core reporter pide que
esto SI sia prica see applique a parte
del dos mil binti quadro there are many
people who are unhappy and who are
frustrated by the fact that sinks
related to gender balance are usually
passed with problems or to not pass in
our votes but there are also people for
whom this is already going too far the
reforms electoral system will be put to
the test in the next elections in 2019